Democratic congressman Adam Schiff
chairman of the House Intelligence
Committee says Attorney General bar is
quote proven to be unreliable and
misleading the Chairman is with us this
morning from Capitol Hill good morning
mr. chairman good morning let me pick up
where Nancy from Nancy's report there so
there is this discrepancy which we're
learning about between Muller and Barr
but as the Department of Justice says it
was the entire report was released where
there are some redactions but the report
was released and Muller did not appear
to have any just didn't think there was
anything inaccurate or misleading in the
summary that Barr put out so isn't this
just kind of a quibble here when you've
got 488 pages to look at of the actual
report no not at all and frankly after
getting now two or three misleading
summaries from the Justice Department
through the Attorney General I don't
think we can rely on the Justice
Department to be summarizing what Bob
Muller said in that conversation to bill
Barr we know from Muller's own words
from that letter that he viewed the Mars
the bar summary as misleading as
essentially allowing the White House to
create this false narrative no this is a
serious business what bar is gonna have
to explain today is why he deliberately
misled the Congress his statements in
particular representative Crist
when representative Crist asked him are
you aware of these reservations that
were reported in the press by Bob Muller
and bars answer was no that was
deliberately false and misleading so and
you know I think the additional question
John is we suspected before we got the
report that Muller produced his own
summary so why did Barr feel it
necessary to create his own summary to
help the White House in this way and now
we know that not only did those
summaries exist but that Muller had
pleaded with him to release those to the
public so I'll ask it this way did the
Attorney General lie to Congress I think
his statement is is deliberately false
and misleading and yes most people would
consider that to be a lie he's a very
smart man he knew exactly what he was
being asked
Congress and he knew his answer was
false
so look there's no sugarcoating this I
think he should step down it's hard I
think for the country to have confidence
in the top law enforcement official in
the country if he's act as the direct
question as he was and he gives a
directly false answer so this is this is
serious business it it is you know after
the after two years of work in an
investigation implicating the President
nighted States for the Attorney General
to mislead the public for an entire
month before releasing that report is
inexcusable are you concerned
congressman that bar and the White House
have now shaped the narrative on this
story and that what really will change
consider what will really come out of
this hearing today no matter what he has
asked well I am concerned that for a
month the country was misled into
believing that these talking points of
the president his mantra was somehow
borne out by this report when it wasn't
and the fact that the Attorney General
of the United States would allow himself
to be used that way doesn't inspire not
only confidence in this investigation
but in the administration of justice and
this was I think probably the most
salient point of that Muller letter and
that is it undermines the public
confidence now in this investigation and
after two years of a hard work I can
understand why mother would be so upset
about it in terms of the hearing today I
think the Congress needs to get to the
bottom not just the bars
misrepresentations but the the
fundamental issue of why Bar arrogated
to himself to make a decision on
obstruction bar you know postulates that
he was required to do this even suggests
that he was invited to do this none of
that is true he could have simply said
that Muller want to present this to
Congress and that's what I'm doing we're
not allowed to indict him and therefore
we're not going to pronounce judgment
we're going to leave that to Congress
that's not what bill Barr chose to do he
chose to be the personal lawyer for the
president instead chairman you have
asked for Bob Miller's special counsel
to testify the Attorney General has said
he has no problem with it do you have a
date set for that what's holding it up
and when will you be given the
underlying evidence we don't have a date
and we've asked for one and we pressed
for one and I think what we're seeing is
a continuation of the same and that is
bar wanted his testimony to go first he
wanted to continue to push out
I think this misleading narrative before
the country actually gets to hear from
Muller so you know we have a month long
unnecessary delay before the report
comes out of course there was no
necessity for bar to put out his own
statement or letter before that came out
and now we have bar again wanting to
delay Muller so that he can further
cement this misleading narrative well
that may serve the president well but
that's Rudy Giuliani's job it's not the
Attorney General the United States job
all right chairmanship we're gonna have
to leave it there thanks so much for
being with us